one of the highlights of the quarantine
and that is the reunion of The Fresh
Prince of bel-air cast but here's the
big question is this the last time we'll
see them together this be the start of
at least there being a special or you
guys doing something together again it
would be wonderful if NBC decided that
they wanted to do but couldn't there be
a spin-off or something like that
possibly but I can't see a reboot of The
Fresh Prince of bel-air ever really
taken place little-known fact I actually
had to decide whether I wanted to do the
Fresh Prince of bel-air or go on and
become a new character on a different
world where actually I would have been
playing alongside Jada I really like the
way that sounds Wow and I chose
obviously The Fresh Prince Oh My yes and
the revelations don't end there would
you believe before there was Will and
Jada there was almost Jada and Alfonso
it was literally one day me it went out
one time and fresh press wasn't even oh
yes I think I would just remember him
being cheerful and fun now Alfonso is
happily married to his wife of seven
years Angela and together they are
tackling homeschooling and other
pandemic pressures I've got two kids on
two different computers on two different
parts of the house and then I got the
little one who was now walking and so my
wife made me with one and I'm with the
other in little one's life I'm just
gonna go explain the stairs and your two
front it's it's madness Ava turned 1
yesterday and this weekend she's making
her America's Funniest Videos debut on
the special AFV at home we have one
video with my daughter Ava eating
peaches for the first time
[Music]
Alfonso's hosting for home so expect the
unexpected and you can't do that my wife
one will sign this out to get my kid go
let's go to do one of his classes see
that's what happens America even what
you do
Entertainment Tonight interviews
[Music]